[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique nous ignorions nous
inaugurerons ce soir et ce sera ainsi
jusqu'au premier tour de la
présidentielle le 10 avril un format
spécial nous recevons des personnalités
des responsables qui sont spécialistes
de grands sujets qui structurent les
débats en france et ce soir nous
recevons manuel valls bonsoir au choix
vous avez en tant que premier ministre
affronter des problématiques majeures
sécurité terrorisme vous avez aussi été
premier ministre bien sûr vous avez été
ministre de l'intérieur parle on est
premier ministre et vous avez aussi
affronter des sujets relatifs à la
sécurité alors là à grande échelle la
sécurité internationale et évidemment
c'est par cela que nous allons commencer
manuel valls la situation s'aggrave
chaque jour davantage a dit tout à
l'heure emmanuel macron s'agissant de
l'ukraine votre analyse dans un instant
dans une quinzaine de minutes brigitte
busch et à mme tran huy nous
interrogeant sur vos convictions vos
propositions en matière migratoire
sécurité les réfugiés justement
ukrainien que doit-on faire pour l'heure
accueilli frère viendra faire un débrief
de l'émission avez vous été clair avez
vous été convaincant et quel rôle
souhaitez vous jouez dans cette campagne
mais on commence par l'ukraine manuel
valls douzième jour de guerre j'ai une
question assez simple que tout le monde
se pose est ce que la situation vous
fait peur
parce que j'ai gouverner parce que j'ai
l'expérience parce que d'une certaine
manière on arrive à prendre un peu de
distance on évite d'avoir peur mais j'ai
le sentiment comme beaucoup et notamment
discutant avec mes concitoyens et que
mes proches que nous sommes en train de
basculer vraiment dans un autre monde
c'est vrai que le monde a profondément
changé depuis au fond la fin de l'ordre
de yalta avec la chute du bloc
soviétique à la fin des années 80 que la
globalisation d'une certaine manière a
bouleversé tous les deux les celle de ma
génération là où je me suis construit
intellectuellement et est politiquement
mais nous sommes en train de basculer
dans quelque chose à partir du moment où
la guerre revient vraiment sur le
continent européen et où il ya en plus
derrière la menace agitée de
l'apocalypse nucléaire d'eau oui
forcément il y à une angoisse une forme
de peur qui nous étreint tous les faux
regarder ça aussi froidement pour voir
quelles sont les solutions et les
chemins qu'il faut désormais emprunter
puisque si un changement de monde il
faut un changement logiciel il faut des
changements profonds dans dans nos
visions dans nos politiques alors est-ce
qu'on vous en parle et vous avez dit
vanasse nucléaire jusqu'aux poutine
peut-il aller à votre avis besoin d'un
public l'a dit que tout était possible
nous que le le pire était devant nous
devant nous
chacun d'entre nous peut être parce que
sommes rationnelle parce que nous
regardons les choses avec avec méthode
parce que nous vivons dans des sociétés
démocrates nous disent on ne peut pas
franchir un certain nombre de pas et
puis il faut faire attention à évoquer
notamment la question de l'utilisation
de la dissuasion nucléaire parce que ce
sont des choses lourdes grave j'en sais
quelque chose comme chef du gouvernement
parce que le premier ministre notre
constitution a une responsabilité aussi
bien sûr sous
sous la responsabilité sous l'autorité
du chef de l'état du président la
république mais
nous voyons bien que tout est possible
que tous les risques sont devant nous
d'abord celui de la guerre
conventionnelle mais aussi de tensions
qui peuvent amener au pire dont tout
doit être fait ce sont des mots qu'on
nous en sommes pour un processus de
désescalade et qu'on n'arrive pas au
pire mais ça veut bien dire qu'il faut
sans agiter des peurs inutiles sans
angoisse est plus que nécessaire nos
compatriotes donc il faut leur parler
faire preuve de pédagogie la presse les
journalistes sur place d'une manière
générale fond de mon point de vue dans
notre pays un travail tout à fait
remarquable les experts les spécialistes
et ce évidemment qui gouverne c'est
important de parler d'expliquer de faire
comprendre aux français où nous allons
et les journalistes nous raconte ce qui
se passe sur le terrain ce qu est
affreux les bombardements maintenant
continue sur certaines villes dont on
voit la destruction et on entend les
ukrainiens on attend on entend le rappel
ou secours parfois on le voit je sais
pas si on peut regarder cette image d'un
panneau qui a été qui a été installé à
kiev où il est indiqué il faut que
l'otan voilà nato doigts
fermer le ciel nato évidemment c'est
l'acronyme de l'otan en anglais l'otan
doit fermer le ciel je vous pose tout de
suite cette question ses appels au
secours des ukrainiens pour fermer le
ciel donc pour que les russes cessent
les bombardements l'otan a dit non il
s'est même pas deux il n'y a pas de voie
de qui permettrait d'aider et de
répondre favorablement aux ukrainiens
ces appels nous angoisse nous avons en
plus tous des amis des proches
craignent un
et donc nous entendons l'angoissent de
ces de ces hommes de ces femmes de ses
concitoyens européens
mais l'ukraine ne fait pas partie de
l'alliance atlantique
établir cette zone
d'exclusion aérienne voudrait dire une
implication pour la faire respecter dès
de l'aviation des pays membres de
l'alliance atlantique donc nous
rentrerions très directement en conflit
avec la russie alors que nous le disons
je sais bien que tout ça est subtile
mais la subtilité est importante cela
dit ce que vous dites il le sait
pourtant la nuit dernière encore il a
lancé l'appel se bat parce que ce
président qui n'est pas dire on l'a
présenté comme le le coluche et pourtant
dieu sait que je l'aimé coluche ou le dp
grillo ukrainien parce que c'est un
acteur un coming ne s'est par ailleurs
quelqu'un qui fait des études de droit
des études économiques c'est
je les croisais dans une réunion à kiev
il ya deux ans et demi c'était juste
quelques mois avant l'élection
présidentielle était déjà le favori des
sondages il maîtrisait déjà beaucoup
elle était d'une manière encore acteur
mais bon hills il se il se révèle vous
savez - par ma part mes origines
forcément même si l'histoire ne se
répète pas elle bafouille et toutes les
comparaisons sont ont forcément leurs
limites mais ça ça me rappelle
historiquement ce que fut la guerre
d'espagne la non intervention des pays
occidentaux le soutien aux républicains
espagnols face aux frontistes c'était le
prélude de la guerre mondiale j'arrête
là ce que
ces comparaisons je le représente par
exemple nous mènerons peut-être dans une
impasse maintenant on voit bien il ya
quelque chose c'est pour ça que nous les
aidons d'abord par une activité
diplomatique visant et c'est presque
impossible présent république l'a dit
encore aujourd'hui pour imposer un
cessez le feu nous leur livrons des
armes pour aider leurs soldats à se
battre et nous imposons un régime de
sanctions aux dirigeants et à l'économie
russe pour les faire reculer mais mais
mais manuel mâcon a été très sincère il
ya quelques minutes dans une réunion
publique à poissy en disant que le
risque majeur c'est que la guerre
continue et que l'offensive russe
continue est ce qu'il a dit en effet que
la lumière poutine refaisait
cessez-le-feu et avec d'ailleurs une loi
marque voulait de faire c'est que comme
l'ukraine est un pays démocratique
l'apprécier présente donc encore
aujourd'hui grâce aux journalistes
reporters de guerre c'est un métier dans
votre métier qui est un indispensable
ils font ce travail je moi j'ai une
conviction mais mais mais évidemment il
ya des vies qui sont en jeu c'est que la
russie ne gagnera pas la bataille de
l'ukraine elle gagnera peut-être cette
guerre elle écrasera peut-être au dessin
et kiev sous sous les bombes mais elle
détruira le détruira les centres
névralgiques et l'ukraine mais elle ne
peut pas gagner de cette manière elle
l'a perdue qui n'en a cure mais elle a
perdu moralement cette guerre l'ukraine
a démontré qu'elle était constitué d'un
peuple courageux et qu'elle formait une
nation une grande partie des des
russophones eux mêmes se sentent
aujourd'hui profondément ukrainien mais
par de façon manuelle base parfois on a
là on a le sentiment qu en france les
responsables
se paye un peu de mots en disant mais
oui ya la guerre mais la russie ne peut
pas perdre mais en
l'ukraine peut être vaincu il peut y
avoir des milliers de morts et bloqué
des gens c'est cela qui importe
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si on peut
sauver quelque chose parce que si on si
la russie perd mais dans des années
c'est une tragédie pour lire un mot
puisque nous ne sommes pas sur place et
que nous ne vivons pas cette situation
nous essayons les uns les autres de
décrire 7,7 cette situation nous aurions
aimé que cela ne se passe pas ainsi et
la france et les autres pays la france
et l'allemagne notamment dans le cadre
du format de de minsk ont jusqu'au bout
tenté d'empêcher cette cette guerre il y
a une volonté elle est inscrite depuis
yeux vous font une bonne quinzaine
d'années dans l'esprit de vladimir
poutine de d'avancé de combattre les
valeurs de l'occident et considère
notamment depuis la révolution orange
d'ukraine et depuis notamment les
événements la place de maidan qui ne
peut pas avoir cette démocratie
ce système qu'il combat il l'a
d'ailleurs théorisé dans un article du
financial times il n'y a pas si
longtemps emmanuel macron lui avait
répondu au fond il oppose deux modèles
sa vision lui d'une démocratie qui est
la sienne autoritaire brutale et un
autre avec nos valeurs il nous considère
faible en plus et donc ils considèrent
que à ses portes il ne peut pas y avoir
non pas une api qui représenterait un
danger pour lui ce n'est pas le cas
encore moins dirigées par des nazis
c'est insupportable président et le
premier ministre ukrainiens sont juifs
voyez-vous tout ça est totalement
absurde mais il n'y a aucune volonté de
guerre de l'ukraine vis-à-vis de la
russie mais et puis de l'idée de la
neutralisation de l'ukraine est même
portée par le président ukrainien donc
mais mais il ne supporte pas qu'il y ait
cette démocratie avec c'est avec ces
valeurs qui sont contraires aux siennes
c'est pour ça qu'ils veulent aller
jusqu'au bout et qu'il veut et kras donc
oui oui nous pouvons vivre pendant des
années avec cette situation une ukraine
détruite avec une partition mais mais
les russes qui ont de lourds problèmes
économiques depuis longtemps c'est un
pays c'est un grand pays par sa culture
et sur l'histoire mais qui a une
démographie tigresse une espérance de
vie grèce une économie
économiquement c'est le sait le sait le
grand risque que fait courir
vladimir poutine à son pays et à son et
son peuple tout cela déstabilise et ce
pays peut-être à terme et peut
déstabiliser aussi l'économie mondiale
nous envoyer européenne je voudrais
qu'on en parle l'europe fait front avec
l'allemagne en a beaucoup parlé alors
pour le coup c'est un sujet de
satisfaction quand même sursaut européen
elle fait front l'allemagne a décidé de
se réarmer d'autres pays aussi faut-il
pousser
je veux dire les feux pour aller jusqu'à
la création d'une armée européenne
vont vite là
c'est vrai que l'europe se se construit
souvent par par les crises en tous cas
l'idée d'avoir bien sûr une diplomatie
c'est le cas mais une autonomie de
défense une autonomie stratégique dont
au fond
forme d'armé européenne c'était un
pilier européen
de l'alliance atlantique
ou autonome avec sa propre puissance de
feu ce qu'on parle d'armes et oui sur
tout ce qui nous oblige les allemands
l'ont dit on voir comment ils vont le
faire à reconstruire pour ce qui les
concerne une armée pour ce qui nous
concerne ce que nous avons déjà une
armée à augmenter les moyens capacités
de défense mais a changé aussi le
logiciel jusqu'à maintenant nous avons
une armée qui se projette plutôt à
l'extérieur c'est le cas bien sûr tout
ça en tête en afrique en afrique de
l'ouest ça veut dire que c'est une armée
qui avec avec sa propre armée de terre
avec davantage de chars de drones
de changements majeurs aujourd'hui d'une
armée européenne on a par exemple en
france un président qui est chef des
armées est ce qu'il faut qui est il
qu'il est ses prérogatives cantine en
conflit en europe et qui un chef des
armées européennes le président de lé
plus loin la france a sa propre
autonomie stratégique ça fout la
dissuasion nucléaire nous sommes le seul
pays de l'union européenne à avoir bien
sûr aussi la grande bretagne qui possède
7 à cette armée ils sont plus membres de
l'union européenne sont membres
permanents du conseil
sécurité et puis tous les pays n'ont pas
la même la même culture là même la même
histoire les mêmes les mêmes moyens il
ya un débat par exemple en espagne à
partir du seul fait que le gouvernement
espagnol son président a décidé de
livrer des armes à l'ukraine ou voyez ce
n'est la force me semble-t-il
de la france de l'allemagne sans doute
aussi de l'italie et d'autres pays c'est
cette converger dans ce pilier européen
de l'otan'' c'est de mettre des moyens
en commun et donc d'avoir les moyens on
les fait d'une réponse y un pays de
l'alliance atlantique aujourd'hui
pays baltes
communauté russophone importante la
pologne la roumanie je parle des pays
frontaliers de la russie ou la
biélorussie qui sont membres de
l'alliance atlantique était attaqué la
laure nabat theuriau l'article l'article
5 de l'alliance atlantique dont nous
rentrerions là dans un conflit lorsqu'on
appelle un conflit à caractère mondial
en tout cas européen on dit ça oui on le
dit on a envie de s'arrêter repas
histoire mais et moi même je m'arrête
pas ce que je je suis conscient de la
delà de la gravité du du coupon en tout
cas on perdre au haut risque mais on ne
peut plus rien espérer détrôner en tout
cas il faut s'y préparer voici près
pareil vite ça veut dire qu y compris
des efforts en matière de défense le
budget la défense aujourd'hui c'est au
tour de 50 milliards à la programmation
militaire a prévu d'augmenter avait
prévu déjà d'augmenter ce budget il
faudra continuer dans ce sens mais ce
n'est pas uniquement de l'argent c'est
une nouvelle stratégie un nouveau
logiciel le chef d'état-major de nos
armées l'a déjà écrit il ya plusieurs
mois les parlementaires ce que nous
sommes sur lcp public sénat l'écrivent
aussi dans des rapports qui ne sont pas
que confidentielle et qui sont de très
grande qualité la présidente de la
commission la défense de l'assemblée
nationale
dumas aussi
réfléchi à ces questions là dont on est
dans un mouvement qui nous oblige en
effet à faire de l'europe une grande
puissance une puissance pas uniquement
économique ce que nous sommes mais
stratégique donc en matière de défense
ça mettra du temps mais il faut le faire
je crois que nous n'avons plus le choix
il en va d'une certaine manière de la
défense de ce que nous sommes c'était
une grande civilisation démocratique
c'est très clair et c'est passionnant on
va faire un petit stop sur ce sujet on y
reviendra tout à l'heure parce que
aujourd'hui on a aussi appris que
bruxelles commencé à instruire la
demande d'intégration de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne vous nous direz tout
à l'heure si l'on met pas la charrue
avant les boeufs si je puis dire mais
d'abord on va faire un petit détour par
le figaro live et on accueille vincent
roux vincent roux bonjour à vous vous
rendez vous regardez les questions en
l'occurrence alternative à ce dossier
ukrainien qui intéresse électeurs et y
en a une qui qui peut soulever des
interrogations aussi auprès de l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur que vous êtes
manuel valls avoue vincent et ancien
premier ministre et ancien élu
au catalogue bonsoir manuel valls soir 2
2 nouveaux rassemblements ont lieu ce
soir en corse également sur le continent
notamment à aix en provence en soutien à
yvan colonna condamné à perpétuité pour
l'assassinât du préfet erignac est battu
à mort mercredi dernier par un détenu
djihadistes à la prison d'arles gilles
simeoni le président du conseil
territorial de corse les manifestants
ont mis en cause l'état et réclame
aujourd'hui le regroupement de ces
prisonniers sur l'île de beauté
est ce que vous y êtes opposés ce soir
il faut être très clair général je suis
clair sur ces sujets là que j'espère sur
d'autres aussi ce qui s'est passé dans
la prison d'arles est inacceptable
mais il y à une enquête du parquet
antiterroriste et j'imagine qu'il ya
aussi une enquête s'était annoncée de
l'administration pénitentiaire pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et bien
sûr il faudra en tirer toutes les
conclusions compris en terme de sanction
est tout à fait anormal qu'un détenu
quel qu'il soit et en l'occurrence yvan
colonna soit agresser semble-t-il
pendant plusieurs minutes par un détenu
lui-même considéré comme
particulièrement dangereux
un ancien jihadiste
ça c'est pour
l'enquêté moi je peux je peux entendre
la douleur de ceux qui sont proches de
colonna et de sa famille
ensuite pour ce qui concerne le
rapprochement des prisonniers en général
ça c'est une question qui est traités
par nos textes par nos règles et par
l'administration pénitentiaire mais par
justice d'application des peines et joue
pas pourquoi moi je ne suis pas
favorable mais en général et surtout
encore moins sous le coup de l'émotion
futile fut-elle légitime là il ya des
règles qu'il faut respecter
et troisièmement
moi j'ai du respect pour gilles simeoni
que je connais mais ce que j'ai vu je
n'évoque même pas la violence qui a eu
vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre à corte
en corse c'est qu'on sait qu'on utilise
cette malheureuse affaire puis nous ne
savons pas encore quel est le sort
médical d'yvan colonna même si
malheureusement de ses proches d il ya
il ya beaucoup de risques mais on compte
utilisent ces manifestations et cette
situation pour faire ni vent colonna un
héros de nouveau en corse il a été
condamné pour avoir assassiné
le préfet erignac le préfet delà de la
république
1998 si ma mémoire ne me fait pas défaut
donc ça pour moi c'est inacceptable
et donc il ya des faits inacceptables à
la prison d'armes le reste je le vois
bien c'est beaucoup de politiques mais
j'imagine que le gouvernement est
attentif à la situation en corse mais on
sent bien que derrière il ya une volonté
de pousser les feux sur ce sujet merci
beaucoup vincent roux merci en direct du
figaro livevault présente brigitte
boucher lcp et tam trân huu et de public
sénat qui vont vous interroger mme
intentions généreuses séquence de cette
guerre en ukraine aussi dans le débat
français et oui les conséquences sur la
campagne présidentielle
puisque effectivement la guerre en
ukraine elle balaye tout le débat de la
campagne présidentielle est confisqué
par la gravité de la situation
internationale
les candidats aujourd'hui peuvent
réellement faire campagne pour vous moi
je vous reproche sur le mot confisqués
parce que bon c'est
aucun candidat encore - emmanuel macron
qui a demandé à vladmir poutine jeu je
le choses à peine plaisanté sur ce sujet
là vu le drame que nous connaissons qui
ont organisé ou qui ont demandé aplanir
poutine d'organiser cette confiscation à
travers la guerre en l'ukraine et donc
les candidats sont un contexte c'est
ainsi empêcher péter le tragique salle
vite dans dans cette campagne l'histoire
est tragique je les ai souvent dit
notamment quand nous avons connu les
attentats de 2015 et 2016 parce que le
monde est fragile et parce que
l'histoire encore une fois elle et elle
est tragique donc aux candidats à
l'élection présentielle pas de conseil à
donner aux uns et aux autres de ceux de
se hisser à la hauteur d'ailleurs on a
bien vu que les candidats je pense à
trois d'entre eux qui sur ces questions
là avaient des positions très
différentes marine le pen eric zemmour
jean luc mélenchon que plus que je ne
confonds pas les uns et les autres mais
en tout cas on voit bien qu'ils qui le
les uns parce qu'il était très proche de
vladimir poutine et de ses thèses les
deux candidats à l'extrême droite jean
luc mélenchon qui fait des propositions
assez étonnante enfin il est versé aux
débats et vous dirais qu'ils sont
disqualifiés c'est non non non moi je ne
dis rien de tout cela d'ailleurs je dis
à tous j'ai dit à des mauges entendent
parler de cinquième colonne des collabos
d'être n 1 mais en tout cas oui ils ont
dit que vlad me fallait un meuble admire
poutine français c'est le cas d'eric
zemmour ils ont chanté les relations
qu'ils avaient avec la dîmière poutine
même si selon variant leurs difficultés
mais forcément grande difficulté mais il
s'agit de quoi cette élection
présidentielle d'élire le ou la
président de la république c'est à dire
celui qui a en charge l'essentiel et
notamment qui sur ces questions
internationales et défense joue un rôle
essentiel
martichon rappeler que le présent le
public elle chef des armées dont je
pense que les français sur un sujet
aussi important ou parle de guerre et de
paix deux sont en capacité de juger les
uns et les autres d'envoyer ce n'est pas
rien des droits par ailleurs l'avocat un
débat même si la campagne est courbe il
faut qu'il y ait un débat intense devant
les français parce que sinon il pourrait
y avoir une très grande frustration
démocratique pour le craignais qu'il
puisse y avoir des rancoeurs qui
s'exprime ensuite une frustration
démocratique soit pas mal de rancoeur
qui s'exprime dans notre pays''
situation internationale est terrible et
notre pays lui-même est inflammable on
l'a bien vu au co2 de ses de ces
dernières années donc il faut qu'ils
aient ce débat démocratique
présidentielle relative parce que sinon
il ya la rancoeur il ya le risque de pas
être allé jusqu'au bout de cette
discussion démocratique
et puis ça se passe ensuite dans la rue
dans une démocratie qui est déjà à
brigitte vous dites qu'il faut qu'il y
ait un débat devant les français
visiblement emmanuel macron prend du
plaisir à débat devant les français
c'est ce qui a lieu d'ailleurs en ce
moment mais ce qu il n'esquive pas du
coup le débat avec ses concurrents
l'impression qui n'a pas très envie
finalement de débattre face après ses
principaux adversaires on verra il peut
il peut il peut surprendre c'est
j'imagine pour lui la difficulté
désormais parce que il doit à la fois
mener cette campagne il le sait bien et
de l'autre côté il prend énormément de
temps et le temps le prends beaucoup
parce qu'il faut discuter avec vladimir
poutine demain avec le chancelier
d'allemagne le président xi jinping le
président chinois il y à un sommet des
chefs d'état de gouvernement dans
quelques jours à versailles il ya des
décisions économiques elle apprend donc
c'est extrêmement lourd et ça ça
participe
ça vous sur sur les médias à travers les
candidats et j'imagine qu'emmanuel m'a
convaincu ici prêtera forcément
participera de ce débat un débat avant
le premier tour entre candidats je pense
que c'est toujours possible il ya des
formes qui existe un débat des douze
candidats on l'avait pas vue en 2012
quand nicolas certains quand nicolas
sarkozy était sortant c'était le cas en
2017 c'est pas le meilleur moment de
télévision on peut se mettre d'accord
mais y avoir des débats des
interpellations la presse d un vite et
feront sur des grandes émissions de
télévision le travail puis orales débat
entre les deux tours aussi entre les
deux qualifiés ont ces gens qui sont que
rien n'est joué ce sont les justes c'est
ce que j'allais vous demandez pas ce que
on voit qu emmanuel macron est très haut
dans les sondages aujourd'hui il ya eu
un effet aussi guerre en ukraine il est
autour de 30 % est-ce que vous pensez
que il ya un ralliement au drapeau qui
peut jouer jusque jusqu'au 10 avril si
cette guerre se poursuit c'est ce qui
est vrai c'est que même mac ont été déjà
si on regarde les enquêtes d'opinion
avec toute la prudence nécessaire et
déjà à ses favoris
marie l'art de la litote pour décrire
cette situation il est le chef d'état il
est le chef de l'état est présent à
public et les français se rassemblent
autour de lui donc ces phénomènes ne
m'étonne pas et démontre qu'il a aussi
en capacité de tenir bon face à ces
crises mais les français sont un vieux
peuple démocratique pétri d'expériences
frondeurs bon donc la qualification
n'est pas assurée à ce que vous ne dites
rien rien n'est sûr et et moi je suis
convaincu que c'est là le sentiment
aussi du présent la public c'est à dire
que il faut mener campagne il faut
combattre même si forcément il faut
forcément ça se passera dans des
conditions différentes et on parle des
prix de pouvoir d'achat oui puisque avec
la guerre en ukraine les prix augmentent
ceux de l'énergie celui des matières
premières on voit notamment les
agriculteurs qui sont inquiètes on sort
du salon de l'agriculture les
consommateurs vont le vivre aussi qu'est
ce que vous proposez face à cet énorme
problème qui va se poser en matière de
pouvoir d'achat c'est ce qui ce qui est
vrai c'est que nous vivions déjà une
crise énergétique du fait de la
fête de la crise que nous avons connue
de la création internationale jeremic de
la situation internationale
et là on a
plus de 2 euros à la pompe un brin tu le
baril de pétrole qui est à plus de 140
euros et puis on a en effet des matières
premières le blé aussi qui eux qui
augmente donc et on voit que les bourses
continuent de s'effondrer donc une
incitation à la fois économique et
financière qui est particulièrement
dangereuse bande ou que j'entends de la
part du du gouvernement et les autres
gouvernements européens
c'est qu'en plus de traiter la crise
ukrainienne est elle même est bien le
quoi qu'il en coûte les soutiens vont
vont se poursuivre un autre
atout ses secteurs qui sont en grande en
quoi un côté look mais le quoi qu'il en
coûte et sans doute nécessaire il va se
poursuivre cet d'ailleurs été annoncé on
laissera pas tomber un certain nombre de
secteurs en revanche
c'est le pouvoir d'achat des français
qui va être touchée grever on était
entrés dans un cycle parfait sans doute
mais de négociations dans les branches
ou des entreprises avec des résultats
satisfaisants ici avec
pouvoir d'achat
des augmentations de salaires d'une
augmentation de pouvoir d'achat en
tenant compte évidemment du niveau
d'inflation qui chez nous je parle en
france étaient moins importants
qu'ailleurs parce que moi encore une
maîtrise du prix de l'énergie grâce à la
part du nucléaire dans dans
l'électricité mais on voit bien que la
situation économique pour beaucoup de
secteurs où une nouvelle voiture pouvoir
d'achat selon voire
d'une augmentation faut faire attention
ce que je veux dire peuvent faire
attention que c'est la situation de
notre économie ce que je veux dire tout
simplement c'est que ce mouvement
vertueux qui était entamée peut être
stoppée par une situation
difficile je pense qu'on est qu'au début
de cette de cette période de 7 de cette
crise il ya des choix qui sont faites
pas augmenter des impôts est ce que
cette ce mouvement dansé de ne pas
augmenter les impôts dans un tel
contexte ça que vous nous dites est ce
que c'est nabeul de faire face à cette
situation nouvelle économie bon donc
c'est ce que je peux pas me précipiter
mais en tout état de cause non je vois
bien qu'il faudra y faire face en aidant
les secteurs concernés en tenant compte
de la demande de pouvoir d'achat mais je
peux rajouter quelque chose j'évoquais
tout à l'heure avec elizabeth martichoux
la nécessité d'augmenter dans les années
qui viennent de manière très sensible le
budget de la de la défense il ya de
toute façon la redéfinition de la
dissuasion nucléaire qui impliquent
aussi des investissements majeurs tout
ça ça se paye c'est là où l'europe doit
pouvoir aussi joué un rôle donc oui là
c'est pour ça que dans le débat
présidentiel
ce que je souhaite modestement c'est que
ses caisses on soit aussi aborder un
autre sujet total énergie et angie
refuse de quitter la russie est ce qu
ils doivent le faire pour vous comme le
fait bp ou shell
moi j'ai le sentiment il ya très peu de
collaborateurs là bas total energy a
annoncé qu'il n'y aurait pas de nouveaux
investissements
de l'autre côté le gouvernement français
visant à demander à ses entreprises
j'allais dire
regardons les choses jour après jour
nous ne nous précipitons pas il y à des
enjeux énergétiques considérables est ce
que tout ceci est tenable à court et
moyen terme vu la situation en ukraine
si demain kiev odessa et d'autres villes
sont écrasés par les bombes rue c est
que l'ukraine se retrouve dans une
situation impossible est ce que tout
ceci sera tenable je ne crois pas je le
dis avec toute la prudence nécessaire
parce que je pense que mes toute parole
publique et notamment celle d'un ancien
prémices doit être la plus la plus
modeste
parents responsabilité et la plus
prudents que possible mais mais ça ne
sera sans doute pas tenable ni
politiquement ni éthiquement ni
économiquement mais si le choix est fait
un moment de se retirer d'un pays comme
la russie de faire d'autres choix en
termes d'alimentation énergétique pour
les pays de l'europe je rappelle que
l'europe le gaz russe doit représenter
20% pour nous 40% pour l'union
européenne est bien plus parfait pour un
certain nombre de pays ça veut dire
qu'il faut changer de modèle énergétique
aller chercher d'autres sources
énergétiques aux états unis en norvège
il faut évidemment engager dès
maintenant
ce mouvement qui est un moment
stratégique mais qui ne se règle pas en
quelques jours et il faut faire
attention à la tension ne connaissons
dans nos sociétés à ce risque de guerre
que nous avons évoqué que nous ne
provoquions pas un effondrement d'un
certain nombre d que le mieux européenne
à commencer par la première d'entre
elles je veux parler des colonials des
réfugiés effectivement plus d'un million
et demi de d'ukrainiens qui ont fui leur
pays on voit que l'allemagne la pologne
plutôt accueille neuf cent vingt mille
réfugiés à elle toute seule qu'elle doit
être selon vous la politique de la
france on voit qu'il ya pas un nez en
naturel très fort aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'elle doit ouvrir grand les bras et
accueillir les ukrainiens sens sans les
comptes et il ya déjà avant la crise il
y avait presque un million et demi
d'ukrainiens en pologne donc les
ukrainiens qui vont en pologne
naturellement c'est le premier pays
qu'il rencontre vont vers leurs familles
vers leurs proches qui sont déjà là bas
il ya des pays comme c'est le cas de la
roumanie c'est le cas aussi d'ailleurs
de l'espagne à 100000 ukrainien qui
vivent depuis longtemps ils vont vers
là-bas il ya aussi une communauté
ukrainienne très importante en amérique
nord et notamment aux états unis nous
avons déjà accueilli je crois 2500 ou
3000 tr lien il faut poursuivre
évidemment ce mouvement c'est le rôle de
l'union européenne et de ses états c'est
le rôle du haut commissariat aux
réfugiés des nations unies des ong des
associations moi je pense qu'il faut
attendre évidemment avec l'idée je le
dis en passant ça me paraît évidemment
essentiel c'est qu'ils puissent y
retourner le plus vite possible en
ukraine mais je ne suis pas naïf et
encore moins cynique bon donc il faut
accueillir ces ukrainiens ce sont nos
frères européens il faut une répartition
européenne ce bel se fera de mon point
de vue je manque c'est assez
naturellement du fait de la présence de
communauté ukrainienne dans les pays
mais oui je pense qu elles deux elles se
fera et là je suis convaincue que la
commission européenne ou si jouera son
rôle de soutien aux états qui le
demanderont ya eu un début de débat
presque un oui oui parce que eric
zemmour dans un premier temps ne voulait
pas que la france accueillent des
ukrainiens il a rétropédalé il a mis des
conditions c'est reprend pas ce que vous
disiez il faut qu'il parle français
qu'ils aient des attaches que ce soit
très temporaire cet accueil est ce que
ce sont les bonnes conditions pour
devoir accueillir des réfugiés ils
craignent en france c'est une espérons
tous qu'elles soient temporaires mais
comme je ne suis pas contradiction est
ce que je dis un instant comme je crains
que ce conflit dure soit de plus en plus
difficile en tout cas dans les jours qui
viennent il faut que nous puissions les
accueillir dans les conditions enfin moi
je vais pas commenter les rétro pédalage
et les amitiés poutinienne de de
monsieur de monsieur et mots il faut
accueillir ces réfugiés dans les
meilleures conditions possibles on a
comparé sa avec les réfugiés syriens oui
j'ai menti mais ça c'est pas l'esprit ya
d'autres mesures et
chaque être humain est le même moi je ne
distingue pas mis en fonction de son
origine sa couleur sa religion ou ou de
sa langue mais mes skis se vient de se
passer en ukraine c'est un mouvement de
départ ces mouvements de réfugiés que
nous n'avions jamais vu en termes de
temps de rapidité la guerre en syrie a
dû commencer en 2011 l'accueil des
réfugiés massif s'est fait en 2015 en
europe la syrie ça n'est pas l'europe
dit il ya une distance géographique faut
traverser des pays la mer méditerranée
de la non classé c'est sur notre sol
c'est un europe directement nous avions
accueilli franche d'ailleurs les pays du
nord de l'europe beaucoup de kosovars
par exemple il ya quelques années au
moment de la guerre
vous comprenez bien
je comprends très bien je veux pas
rentrer dans ce dans ce dans ce dans ce
dans ce débat nous devons accueillir les
réfugiés l'accueil des réfugiés comme
l'asile politique nous parlons je crois
d'immigration tout à l'heure c'est autre
chose il va que vient réfugiés l'asile
c'est à devoir c'est un devoir
humanitaire
moral mais tout ceci est en train
évidemment de s'accélérer regardez nous
n'arrivons la communauté internationale
n'arrive pas imposés aux russes et le
cessez le feu et la possibilité pour les
populations sylla de sentir une petite
clarification sur les uns de vos amis en
juillet jean louis bourlanges la parler
d'une immigration de grande qualité en
parlant des ukrainiens ça fait débat 1
qu'il s'exprime en ces termes avait deux
styles complètement tort pour vous je
joue je ne vois pas de quoi vous parlez
et the good ou de ce qu'ils parlaient
les dix fois cueillir les ukrainiens ça
va être une migration de grande qualité
en révoquant les
la pression intellectuelle qui permet ce
changement d'aile qui alors il y avait
eu ce ce débat en allemagne je vous
rappelle d'une réunion à evian où se
réunissaient les les patronat allemand
et français les patrons allemands chefs
d'entreprises allemands m'avait expliqué
j'étais points mis ce moment là que
c'est formidable parce que parmi les
syriens et beaucoup d'ingénieurs et le
décor plus ça correspondait à une
attente à une demande de 2 de l'économie
allemand ça n'a absolument rien à voir
ce sont des gens qui partent sont pas
des immigrés ce sont là aussi vraiment
des réfugiés ce qui est vrai c'est que
l'ukraine est un pays qui perd de la
population par la russie tout à l'heure
et le fait qu'ils aient un million et
demi d'ukrainiens dans leur pays voisins
parce que la pologne pays dont
l'économie va bien par le fait qu'elle
est dans l'union européenne montre aussi
toutes les difficultés de l'ukraine je
crois qu'on
choisirait des années il s'est réfugié
chez nous des années on a des questions
sur justement la politique migratoire
oui plus largement cette politique
migratoire est ce que pour vous elle
doit passer par des quotas d'immigration
décidé au parlement votée par les
députés ce qu'il faut qu'ils aient aussi
ce débat annuel sur ses quotas moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'ils aient leur
remise à plat de la politique migratoire
parce que avant cette crise mais une
grande partie du sentiment d'impuissance
que les français éprouvent c'est que sur
ces questions là sur les politiques
migratoires ou d'immigration il ya un
échec de la droite et de la gauche
et que au fond l on venait à peu près la
même politique et le même sentiment
d'impuissance constatée face au fait
qu'on n'arrive pas à renvoyer chez eux
ou à la frontière ont expulsé les
déboutés du droit d'asile ou ceux qui
sont en situation régulière sur notre
sol donc il faudra de l'efficacité ce
sont des sujets compliqués on les traite
pas à coup de slogans mais il faut les
traiter
deuxièmement
moi je suis pose une question est ce
qu'on a besoin
d'une immigration du travail qui est une
part relativement faible d'ailleurs dans
l'immigration en général moi je le pense
pas mais mais ça dépend des secteurs
donc si ça dépend des secteurs s'appelle
la forme atik ça peut être le bâtiment
qui est déjà un peu le cas cette
immigration peut être le commerce l'eau
alors voilà déjà riz depuis longtemps et
d'ailleurs des députés de gauche comme
je viendrai ou malek boutih donc proposé
par le par le passé je suis favorable
oui a dit quotas et à ce qu'on vote au
parlement sa demande sans doute une
modification constitutionnelle effectué
ça veut dire que sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres moi je suis vraiment partisan
d'une unité nationale en tout cas de
grand consensus républicain entre les
formations politiques avec les
partenaires sociaux avec des élus locaux
sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres parce
que façon on voit bien qu'il faut sortir
de ce qui a été fait pendant des années
on peut parvenir à ce consensus
justement pourquoi pas électorale je je
je les ai je l'espère parce que ce que
les français demandent ce sont des
solutions concrètes expulsion des
déboutés et de ceux qui n'ont rien à
faire sur le territoire quotas en
manière de politique d'immigration du
travail accueille parce que moi je crois
que c'est quelque chose de très
important des étudiants étrangers comme
nous le faisons parce qu'il faut former
des élites et que parce que le la france
est un grand pays et enfin respect du
droit d'asile qui doit pas une mise en
cause par le fait qu'on n'arrive pas
expulser les déboutés du droit d'asile
et accueille des réfugiés quand il ya
des crises comme celle que nous
connaissions je pense que la france
encore heureusement cette capacité
d'accueil et d'intégration et je
n'oublie pas deux éléments qui me
paraissent essentiels le regard là sont
tournés vers l'est mais que le grand
défi qui reste devant nous c'est la
méditerranée et l'afrique et saluer le
grand projet pour l'europe et enfin
l'essentiel ce qui est cardinals et la
protection de nos frontières communes
européennes ou sud notamment ça c'est le
sujet sinon on reviendra à des
frontières nationales il en sera fini
avec frontex renforcé et plus de moyens
ces coques évidemment quand on parle de
murs on pense au mur de berlin on pense
aux murs de trump aux barbelés je vous
dis pas quoi on pense je rappelle qu'il
existe des barbelés par exemple autour
des des enclaves espagnoles de ceuta et
melilla au maroc que les drames majeurs
aujourd'hui en méditerranée c'est du
côté du détroit de gibraltar ou aux
canaries que la grèce par ailleurs fait
son travail fait son job le soutien de
l'union européenne et qu'elle était en
train de construire des séparations ou
des murs ils ont dit les choses aussi
nettement oui ça veut dire que le
traitement de l'asile les questions ces
questions là c'est là qu'il faut le
traitement faciale les empreintes
digitales il faut un vrai travail pour
se protéger avec dans le respect des
personnes bien évidemment mais il faut
musso nous serions le seul continent
ouvert à tout le moins si nous voulons
être efficaces pour accueillir des
réfugiés ukrainien et dans de bonnes
conditions bah ça veut dire qu'il faut
une politique d'ensemble qui soit
efficace et puissante de l'immigré
avec 62% des français selon un sondage
hoxha qui date du mois de janvier qui
jugent négativement le bilan des manuels
mâcon en matière de sécurité c'est le
raté du quinquennat
c'est en tout cas c'était un sujet de
préoccupation vous connaissez bien vous
avez un oui mais parce que je pense que
la société plus violente mise en cause
de l'autorité il ya un passage à l'acte
il ya par exemple ou au delà des
sondages et des statistiques là
l'augmentation des des homicides ou des
tentatives d'homicides est sans doute le
chiffre le plus inquiétant parce qu'il
démontre cette violence qui existe dans
la société reconnaissant que la pandémie
la période de la pandémie n'a pas
arrangé ses les atteintes aux biens mais
augmenter sans tension ils veulent une
violence dans nos dans nos sociétés moi
je mets c'est un raté ou pas mais je
pense que les questions ont dit comment
régaliennes les grands sujets que sont
sécurité immigration islamisme ont été
sous-estimés au début du quinquennat
sans doute qu emmanuel macron avait
l'idée que au fond son élection
régénérer la vie politique la situation
économique et la croissance ferait
baisser ces tensions donc talent
cardiaque c'est pas le cas il ya une
véritable prise en de conscience sur ces
sujets là
son petit feuilleton là où il ne parle
pas du tout des questions reggae dance à
la truite
dans le domaine de la lutte contre
l'islamisme le discours des murs aux
états est un tournant majeur quelques
jours avant le terrible assassinat de
samuel pâtit la loi dite séparatisme
même si elle a changé de nom à donner
des moyens supplémentaires au ministère
de l'intérieur si cela se fait ce nouvel
lebon voleuse la modernisation de nos
forces de sécurité gérald darmanin est
tamisée l'intérieur qui a vraiment
ouvert le le capot du ministère de
l'intérieur que je ne citais de voiture
et qui sait vraiment plongés dans la
réorganisation de ce que peut être la
police du 20e siècle avec des nouveaux
enjeux comme tout ce qui est lié aux
cyber les assises de la justice alors
c'est venu oui dans cette fin de
quinquennat mais on voit bien qu'il
faudra poursuivre cette cet effort dit
moi je constate qu'après avoir noté
qu'il y avait un déficit au début du
quinquennat il ya eu une prison est ce
que ça ne plaît demande de ces deux
questions jusqu'à sion à commencer par
le président est ce que ça n'arrive pas
trop tard puisque effectivement vous en
parlez emmanuel macron annoncé au mois
de janvier une hausse de 15 milliards
d'euros sur cinq ans à la suite du
beauvau de la sécurité on se dit
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir fait plus tôt
est ce que ce n'est pas justement un
aveu d'échec sur ce qui a été fait au
début l'augmentation des moyens de la
police est désormais constante depuis
2012 parfois j'ai le sentiment que le
monde de commencer en 2010 est non les
choses ont été faites avant y compris en
termes de réforme
de nos services de renseignements il
faut poursuivre cet effort me voit bien
que ce n'est pas qu'une question de
moyens c'est une question de
réorganisation par exemple je suis
convaincu qu'il faudrait recruter quinze
mille stagiaires
qui font les études de droit ou
d'avocats pour les mettre dans les
commissariats où les brigades de
gendarmerie pour délivrer davantage de
ce qu'on fout c'est pas un problème
d'augmentation
policiers les gens n'a ya la question du
temps de travail des policiers et des
gendarmes aussi donc présent pénale vous
connaissez bien oui et ce n'est pas
qu'une question c'est une question de
moyens mais pas seulement bon c'est le
cas des assises dont on écoute et rien
n'est parfait et en tout cas moi je me
l'interdis en ces cas
il ya eu une évolution du président qui
au départ était effectivement pas tout à
fait formation mais mais mais parce que
vous quand vous êtes chef de l'état vous
prenez la réalité dans la figure c'est
précis sur les i jah buzz dans le
football elisabeth moreno a dit qu'elle
était elle pour le port du hidjab dans
le sport féminin est ce que vous êtes
sur sa ligne je suis en général sur ma
ligne
je surtout quand ils volent alors plutôt
sur la ligne de marennes chiapas si je
voulais poursuivre une controverse au
sein du gouvernement mais ce n'est pas
mon rôle
je suis pour l'interdiction de ces
signes religieux comme ils sont
interdits à l'école je suis pour leur
interdiction l'université je n'ai pas
changé de conviction depuis des années
et je suis pour l'interdiction du hijab
dans dans le sport et on voit bien qu'en
plus par la manifestation devant
l'assemblée nationale là il s'agit d'une
provocation c'est un symbole politique
qui en plus souvent des comptes au
moment où des femmes se battent partout
dans le monde depuis des années en iran
ou ailleurs pour retirer le voile aux
ici au nom de la liberté nous explique
que le summum c'est le hidjab ou dans le
sport non non vraiment le sport la place
des fusées les tifos l'université les
accompagnatrices scolaire l'espace
public non les stages public aussi ne le
faites pas dit autre chose d'accord vous
parler sur des situations bien précises
les accompagnatrices scolaire oui parce
que je considère c'est une mission de
service public dans l'espace public
d'une manière générale nous faisons
attention parce que là on rentrerait
dans une confrontation qui me paraît
très dangereuse pour la démocratie en
revanche combattre ce voile qui a un
caractère politique
voile est utilisé aujourd'hui pour
défier la république ne combat
politiquement culturellement
parfaitement
est ce que on couvre le visage des
femmes ou leurs cheveux au nom d'une
vision de la société et des femmes qui
est totalement à l'opposé de ce que sont
nos valeurs les dernières questions pour
faire la transition avec un extraire
toute dernière question votre réaction à
ce que dit la lettre à qui a révélé la
semaine dernière que votre mix au parti
a été aidée financièrement par la
république en marche en 2017 est ce que
vous pouviez faire autrement que
soutenir la candidature d'emmanuel
macron en 2022 a tant donné donc c'est
la corruption vont en découdre mais j'ai
soutenu maquereau en 2000 en 2010 cette
gt le rappelle en passant députés de la
majorité pendant un an et tout ça serait
à cause de soutien bas cenon city
financé nature non non non non je le
confirme ce n'est en rien un problème
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas assez pas
une difficulté mais de là imaginer que
s'est posée questions financières très
honnêtement
non on va reparler de votre
positionnement politique merci beaucoup
roger boucher merci tome 3 de moitié je
voudrais juste revenir d'un mot mais
c'est ça l'actualité on revient une
seconde sur l'ukraine avec la non ce que
l'union européenne lance l'examen des
candidatures de aujourd'hui de l'ukraine
et pas seulement la géorgie la moldavie
est ce qu'on va trop vite
lorsque et c'est une procédure qui prend
du temps mais en tout état de cause est
ce que vous êtes favorable à ce qu'ils
disent oui oui parce que la reine mab
parce que là on a quelque chose qui est
de l'ordre civilisationnel papa du
symbole ça serait trop le trop facile là
là depuis les années à venir poutine et
ce et ceux qui réfléchissent autour de
lui considère que la démocratie est
faible je le disais tout à l'heure que
les européens sont faibles face à face à
eux face à l'as à la brutalité que nous
sommes une société
décadente n'ont donc le tan c'est autre
chose mais sur l'union européenne l'a
maintenant où les dents dans dans
l'ordre sans doute du symbolique mais
aussi dans l'ombre mais civilisationnel
de crisper davantage l'année mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il est relativement
crispé et si on en reste à ces questions
là de toute façon il est il est
déterminé nous ne pouvons pas céder sur
l'essentiel vous présentez frère
directeur adjoint du figaro et
isabelle bon soir
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'attention ce
que vous avez dit si vous voulez bien je
voudrais reprendre sur trois aspects le
premier est évidemment sur la guerre qui
est conduite en europe centrale la
deuxième sur les problèmes régalien
insécurité immigration troisième sur
votre avenir politique première question
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure si
cette guerre se durcit elle est déjà
très dur si elle se durcit à la façon
dont vladimir poutine a conduit sa
guerre en tchétchénie qu'il a pilonné
grozny qui l'a fait la même chose en
syrie qu'est ce que l'europe peut faire
pour éviter et bien que le cren soir
alain rayés de la carte carrément c'est
tout ce qui est engagé jusqu à
maintenant à partir du moment où nous
disons que nous sommes pas en guerre
contre la russie et que les armées de
l'otan'' n'interviendront pas le débat a
lieu aussi aux états unis vous le savez
n'interviendront pas en ukraine c'est
par la persuasion c'est par les
sanctions économiques par l'élévation de
sanctions économiques
ce sera l'un des sujets du sommet
européen
à versailles c'est par la mobilisation
de la communauté internationale
la chine son rôle a joué le chef du
gouvernement israélien a fait aussi un
déplacement à moscou chacun est mobilisé
bien évidemment pendant ce temps là on
bombarde les ukrainiens et nous savons
il présentera public l'a dit encore
aujourd'hui que la guerre va se
poursuivre et que sans doute et vladimir
poutine l'a dit donc il faut en tout cas
à l'écouté il a dit je veux atteindre
mes objectifs
c'est à dire en finir avec les nazis je
reprends ses termes ukrainien
neutralisaient l'ukraine notamment punir
au fond l'ukraine soit de manière
diplomatique parce que vous céder à mes
exigences soit de manière militaire
comme personne ne peut céder à ces
exigences
et donc poursuivre la gare la guerre est
ce que je constate c'est que il ya
encore des pourparlers que il ya encore
des canaux pour se parler mais mais mais
mais oui le jeu devient con tout cela
laisse donc pour faire avancer l'europe
de la défense
articulée avec l'organisation du traité
de l'atlantique nord certes est-ce qu'on
peut pas imaginer que vladimir poutine
soit mis hors jeu
son propre peuple
c est ce que vous le souhaitez non c'est
debout plutôt je ne souhaite pas
répondre à cette question avec tout le
respect que je que je vous dois parce
que alors là précisément si notre
objectif serait de déstabiliser la
russie et de changer nous mêmes les
le pouvoir en russie on change
totalement la nature de ce qui était en
train de se passer ça c'est aux russes
de décider d'agir dans une société 4 nas
et je suis quand même frappé et est
admiratif de tous ces manifestants russe
nombreux semblent team un peu partout en
russie qui manifestent contre la guerre
il y aura des conséquences cette
intervention économique et politique
dans la société russe sans doute de
moyens et de et de et de long terme la
du mal les uns et les autres à lire les
intentions de vladimir poutine et ce qui
se passe en russie il peut se passer des
choses mais je pense que nous avons les
uns et les autres intérêt à être
prudents sur l'utilisation d'un certain
manque de deux concepts à l'aréna une
dernière question sur ce sujet l'un qui
est très prudent c'est joe biden qu'on
n'entend quasiment pas dans ce conflit
alors qu'il a un rôle à jouer évidemment
est ce que le rôle que joue alors
peut-être en coulisses peut-être mais
que joue actuellement joe biden
publiquement est ce qu'il vous satisfait
vous le trouvez en retrait je pense
qu'il est intervenu sur ce sujet là à
plusieurs reprises ils aident
financièrement et militairement
le cren cela a été rappelé le congrès
est sans doute plus allants c'est vrai
que de la société américaine il ya une
très grande prudence sur ce sujet là le
parti républicain notamment depuis
depuis trempe a été quand même
extrêmement lâche je mets des guillemets
vis-à-vis de poutine mais d'une certaine
manière je pense que ce qui est arrivé
est la logique de ce que nous
connaissons depuis des années c'est aux
européens de concert leur destin en
europe nous nous avons des alliés ce
sont les américains mais nous avons
notre propre stratégie à des finales de
leur rappeler vous il ya quelques
semaines mesure où sont les européens le
dialogue n'a lieu que entre poutine et
les américains ébahis des noms l'europe
est en promo ligne c'est normal parce
que malheureusement la guerre entonnant
sachant qu évidemment nous savons que
derrière il ya d'autres enjeux
dans le pacifique dans la zone indo
pacifique avec la question de taiwan
donc j'imagine que le président byden
fait j'imagine qu'ils nous le savons il
a tout cela à l'esprit alors comme j'ai
un droit de suite je vais vous faire
vous regardez quand vous avez déclaré
certaines choses sur l'immigration tout
à l'heure
ça passe pas peut-être pas
ça arrive
alors moi je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
aient leur remise à plat de la politique
migratoire
parce que avant cette crise mais une
grande partie du sentiment d'impuissance
que les français éprouvent c'est que sur
ces questions là sur les politiques
migratoires ou d'immigration il ya un
échec de la droite et de la gauche
et que au fond ils ont mené à peu près
la même politique et le même sentiment
d'impuissance constatée face au fait
qu'on n'arrive pas à renvoyer chez eux
ou à la frontière ont expulsé les
déboutés du droit d'asile ou ceux qui
sont en situation régulière sur notre
sol donc il faudra de l'efficacité sur
des sujets compliqués on les traite pas
à coup de slogans mais il faut les
traiter alors j'ai deux questions la
première c'est il faut les traiter
comment on les traite comment on fait
parce que tous les hommes politiques et
toutes les femmes politiques s'engagent
la thur dix ans mais avec moi on va les
raccompagner à la frontière oui mais
comment on fait ça ne se produit jamais
enfin c'est marginal puisque comme vous
le savez très bien la plupart de ceux
qui sont déboutés du droit d'asile
restent dans notre pays je ne suis
candidat à rien vous avez pas un
candidat ici à la présence d'un public
mais sans vous et j'ai pris sur près de
deux reculs je m'étais exprimé notamment
dans un long papier que vous avez eu
l'amabilité de publié il ya quelques
mois d'antan dans le fil dans le figaro
où j'expliquais ce que je viens de dire
et c'est cette méthode vous avez raison
de dire que l'une des grandes
difficultés
c'est l'expulsion c'est la reconduite à
la frontière pour pau question humaine
question moyens parce que ce peut être
pas que quand même le travail de la
police et la gendarmerie parce qu'il ya
des difficultés avec les pays dit le
premier le premier choix c'est d'arrêter
ce qui était en train de se passer c'est
à dire que de réduire les délais même si
des efforts ont été faits depuis des
années pour ce qui concerne le
traitement la demande d'asile ceux qui
sont déboutés doivent partir dans les
plus brefs délais et évidemment de de
contrôler et d'être beaucoup plus
strictes concernant notamment comme on
les met dans l'avion puisque c'est cet
effet moi je me rappelle c'est un chef
de bord qui décide si d'accept vie mais
je me rappelle alors c'était sur des
sujets spécifiques qui concernait les
afghans ou les albanais qui était sur
calais on a organisé des avions des
charters
communs avec les allemands ou avec
d'autres pays européens pour des renvoi
dans leurs pays respectifs
mais mais mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
une pression il faut des coopération
avec les pays concernés des pays tiers
que ce soit facile bien évidemment non
nous le savons mais en tout cas nous
n'avons pas
cinq minutes entier est alors une
deuxième question sur ce sujet là qui
est passée inaperçue vous avez dit que
vous étiez vous étiez pas sûr que vous
êtes soyez encore favorable à
l'immigration de travail
je pose une question est ce que nous
avons besoin d'une nouvelle immigration
mais c'est ça que je voulais vous poser
comme question je ne crois pas tel qu'en
tout cas nous l'avons pratiqué c'est à
dire qu'on reçoive les réfugiés des gens
comme ça mais pas ce rythme nous
nous n'avons pas forcément dans tous les
secteurs besoin d'une immigration du
travail elle a une part relativement
faible
aujourd'hui dans l'émigration gère la
part la plus importante c'est
l'immigration familiale c'est le roman
familial et les liens familiaux revoir
les règles locke & key propres oui oui
aussi bien évidemment c'est le sait il
faut si on traite pas ces questions là
si on répond pas à la question est ce
qu'on a besoin d'une immigration du
travail dans certains secteurs
tempérament doux l'inique taxe nous
avons il ya des français qui nous
écoutent et qui se disent mais manuel
valls voit bien que dans certains
secteurs professionnels on a besoin de
mille bâbords et sinon
il ya déjà des pénuries d'emploi y avoir
encore plus c'est bien pour cela que je
dis il faut cette politique de quotas
mais qui n'est pas lié l'immigration
familiale bon donc on peut avoir besoin
dans des moments tempérament c'est le
cas aussi dans l'informatique par
exemple ce fut le cas c'était le cas
aussi dans la santé ce qui pose d'autres
questions un médecin infirmière qui
viennent d'autres d'autres pays d'auch
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de ce débat
au parlement de ces politiques de quotas
j'allais dire une discussion sereine si
c'est possible parce qu'on a besoin de
traiter ces questions sinon les traits
d'une manière générale et ça n'avance
pas et ça l'esprit évidemment ensuite à
toutes les démagogies alors vous m'avez
tendu une perche tout à l'heure vous
mais moi je ne suis candidat à rien mais
si vous êtes peut-être candidat à
l'occasion des élections législatives
qui vont avoir lieu au mois de juin
seriez-vous
davanture seriez vous candidat au nom
est bien de la majorité présidentielle
si elle est reconduite du j'ai eu
l'occasion de notre président il raconte
je je je ne crois pas je ne crois pas
parce que j'ai déjà été député pendant
des années je ne pas être candidat par
exemple dans la première circonscription
de l'essonne jor-el et le le député
député sortant de très grande qualité
francis choix beaucoup réfléchissent
aussi à l'avenir bon donc ça n'est pas
complètement sûr oui parce que je pense
qu'il faut attendre que cette élection
présidentielle ait lieu votre décision
après elle peut être amenée je le fais
en fait vous en auriez vous et c'est une
bonne question ces bonnes questions et
vous même nous oui c'est une bonne
question que je me pose à moi même parce
que
comme ancien premier ministre
j'interviens j'écris je donne mon avis
mes conseils et de l'autre côté je vois
bien que la politique est ma vie la
situation que l'on connaît vous oblige à
un engagement supplémentaire est ce que
cet engagement passe pas le rôle qui est
le mien d'anciens premiers ministres des
chartes soit un statut bénévoles et est
ce que ça vous oblige à un moment à
prétendre avoir une responsabilité
parlementaire un mandat d'élu donc la
question pour moi elle peut être ouverte
en tout cas je m'interroge mais ensuite
est-ce que c'est utile est ce que c'est
possible bhl voilà où
oui sur la gauche alors donc à ce que je
vais dire vous préférez de mendès france
ou léon blum mendès france qui
finalement est resté comme un une espèce
de sages de la gauche ou léon blum qui a
été réélu après
du front populaire ce sont deux grandes
références donc je suis modeste par
rapport à l'un et c'est très généreux
hi hi fi biographie de falaise
salat-baroux sur léon blum dans le nid
l'un et l'autre clemenceau c'est-à-dire
au pouvoir après 2,4 mais là on est très
âgée en grand forme ça lui permet de
gagner la guerre mais laissez-moi à
l'espoir pour les 20 ans qui viennent
bien sûr la gauche est pas morte
les idées de gauche ne sont pas mortes
mais la gauche organisé
la gauche dans un espace de partis
politiques willaey leur jeu les inutiles
même dans le oui il est pas parti
socialiste et est mort les électeurs de
gauche françois hollande demain nous
sont comme on dit familièrement chez
emmanuel macron il l'était en 2017 et je
pense qu'ils le seront assez logiquement
encore cette fois-ci en 2022 mais la
gauche par le ton qu'elle n'a pas su
trouver vis-à-vis du pouvoir actuel le
fait qu'elle ait pas dans le débat alors
qu'il y avait une fois faire est en
effet hors jeu voilà envoyer la fifa les
12 candidats qui ont été
sélectionnés si je puis dire validée par
le conseil constitutionnel
merci beaucoup manuel valls assez de
vous entendre dans son édition public ce
soir depuis 19h30 merci frère merci les
filles on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine même heure même endroit 19h30
lcp public sénat bonne soirée sur la
chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]